should you start in network marketing so
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
erica who loves working with people
loves working with parents loves working
with children
and finds that her job is super limiting
and
she's not able to have as big an impact
that she wants to have so she's looking
to get into networking marketing to be
able to quit her job
do network marketing full-time but she's
struggling to achieve her goals
and she asked for my advice on how to
get there so this is a fantastic
question and i have three
bits of advice to help you erica in
making your decision
number one is examine your why why are
you doing this
why are you starting up in the network
marketing industry see a lot of people
starting network marketing because they
think they can make a lot of quick money
right you look at all the websites and
it says
easy way to make an extra thousand
dollars or five thousand dollars or ten
thousand dollars or fifty thousand
dollars a month
and you're unlured by that you wanna
make that extra cash until you sign up
and you typically never get those
results so you have to be doing it for
the right reasons
a lot of people started network
marketing to run away from something
else
you hate your job you hate your city you
hit your family whatever it is you're
running away from something
instead of running towards something and
this is honestly i feel
somewhere that you might be in that gray
zone right now i feel like you're
running away from your job
you feel it's limiting you feel like
you're not getting the potential you
have there and so you're running
towards network marketing as a solution
running away from something
isn't a good enough reason look in
relationships for example
if you're in a relationship with a guy
and you hate it and you got to get out
of it
you don't want to just run away from him
to jump into another relationship to get
away from the first guy
because chances are the new guy isn't
going to work out either instead you
want to design your life on purpose and
run
towards things that support you and if
that means it's network marketing then
by all means
go in for it number two is sell products
you believe in
again so many people jump into network
marketing because they think they can
make tons of money
and they're selling stuff that they have
no product on knowledge or awareness
about
they're selling things that they don't
actually use or actually endorse
how do you expect me to buy something
from you and get excited about it
when you don't actually use it and are
excited about it yourself
whatever business you're in network
marketing or otherwise you need to sell
products and services that you actually
use and love
when you're talking to people i should
feel that passion coming through because
you use that product so much this needs
to be a product or service that you
would recommend to your mother or your
kids to use
erica you said you love working with
parents and kids would you refer
these products to your own parents and
your own kids if you wouldn't then
you'll never have success
with this network marketing company no
matter what strategies people give you
because you don't believe in the product
understanding your why and having a
product that you believe in
are the two most common reasons for
failure
in the network marketing industry if you
solve both of those two then you're
ready for number three
and that's model success you want to
find people who are already doing what
you're doing
really well model their strategies and
apply it to your business
now in a network marketing industry you
should have an upline right you should
have somebody who
recruited you into the business and
somebody recruited them into the
business and ideally you're working with
an upline that is supportive
that gives you training that helps you
it answers your questions that tells you
how they did it
and instead of just recruiting new
people all the time they're actually
concerned about the development of the
people that they bring on
a lot of people have really bad uplines
and you want to make sure that
when you're joining a new opportunity
you have that mentor there to guide you
to help you to become successful
but i'd also take a step beyond that
read books watch videos
learn from successful entrepreneurs who
are in the network marketing business
or otherwise because you can learn from
their strategies
and apply it to make your business
successful starting any kind of business
is hard and to have success you really
need to make sure that you examine your
why
that you sell products and services you
believe in and that you model success
good luck erica and believe for those of
you watching i'd love to hear from you
in the comments your success your
thoughts your opinions on network
marketing i'm going to join in that
discussion with you
and if you like the video you want to
see more don't forget to subscribe to
the channel
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you soon
i'm calvin moyer i'm a singer songwriter
and radio personality
i subscribed to evan's newsletter a few
years ago
it has really helped me the newsletter
is very informative and inspiring
and it has helped me throughout my
career so i encourage you
to don't give up you can make it
subscribe to evan's newsletter today
you won't regret it
you